[Music]
today's question comes from miranda in
mississippi i'm a 20 year old who is
struggling and feel like debt is
inevitable for me i took out a private
loan for five thousand dollars after
paying off my first year and a semester
of school by myself my savings account
has been drained and i have not been the
best budgeter how can i avoid loans when
i have no money i need to be enrolled
and go to school i am at a loss as to
how to move forward
well first of all miranda
i would take a deep breath and give
yourself some grace a lot of people are
not great budgeters when they're 20.
i love that you're asking this question
the fact that you're you know writing in
and you're interested in budgeting says
a lot so
first of all just don't speak that
you're not a great budgeter over you
because i think you have so much room
for growth and a lot of people who start
budgeting don't feel like they're great
budgeters a lot of people are like oh
we say that it typically takes people
about three months to start getting good
at a budget so give yourself grace with
that but with the college situation the
first thing i do is talk to your
financial aid office you're obviously
already in school so sit down with a
financial aid officer and explain your
situation explain that you don't have
the money to pay for school you're not
going to take out any more loans so ask
them you know is there any other extra
funding available a lot of schools offer
discounts
on tuition so see if you're eligible for
any additional discounts to be able to
make ends meet see if there are any
other scholarships available that maybe
you could apply for or that they had
they could actually just give you um and
see if there are any other jobs on
campus but that point person can kind of
explain what's available at your school
so that you can get kind of a true
number that you now need to figure out
so you know that's the very first point
person and then of course working um
getting jobs off campus a lot of times
if you look off campus you can get jobs
that pay a bit more than what you can
find working at the library at your
school or somewhere on campus so see
what's available there
and make 25 an hour cleaning toilets
yup walking dogs
babysitting
a lot of retail jobs are getting close
to that too now yeah
and uh miranda you're not working
there's nothing in here that indicates
at all that you're doing any work
and you need to work like a lot
yep like all the time
like 40 hours a week
how do i go let's go you're gonna go to
school you're just not gonna have much
of a social life oh well
so what is the what is the goal here
what's the primary goal if i could only
get one thing done in the next four
years social life
or school which am i going to do
because you're going to choose well it's
to give the rest of your life to have a
great social life so
be willing to invest now and work hard
so that you can really enjoy and have
freedom after you graduate it's just a
temporary sacrifice for a really massive
long-term benefit
and then also when you're looking at
jobs off campus though really be
strategic don't just jump on the first
job that you see a lot of companies are
offering tuition benefit programs so see
if you can get a high hourly rate plus
see if you can find somebody who'll
actually pay for your college tuition or
give you a portion of that because
there's a lot of people out there doing
that and you want to be as strategic as
possible
yeah i you know there was a thing and i
think it's still rolling out there that
a bunch of these companies fedex ups
target chili's
several of these other companies were
offering school tuition
and work yeah it's actually and the work
is like 20 an hour
i mean it's it's yeah so look for stuff
like that
well the challenge with that is you may
need to transfer to make that happen so
a lot of these jobs are offering free
tuition benefits for certain colleges so
i don't know what college you're going
to you may be going to a college that
costs 60 000 a year and if you have no
money and you're not getting a lot of
financial aid or scholarships from that
school you may need to consider going
somewhere else and going to a job that
offers free tuition benefits and it may
be to a state school it may not be to
the most you know prestigious school in
the area but if it's free
that's incredible you can graduate that
free and still get a great job yep
absolutely absolutely i prestige the
prestige of the school does not enter
into the decision at all you don't have
any money
and so and prestigious schools have no
track record whatsoever of causing you
to be successful zero
so i don't really care about the
prestige of the school at all
you need to be studying something that's
applicable and studying it people that
are really reasonable and teaching it
and get plugged in so i don't know where
you are in mississippi miranda but
lots and lots and lots of hard work lots
of plugging into companies that while
you're working and earning money also
have scholarship programs getting
scholarships going to the counselor's
office like uh christina is saying here
and all of that comes together and where
you're going to school
how you're working and how you're
getting scholarships those are the three
things that get people through debt free
but i think it's important for sometimes
people to stop and go i may not be at
the right school i think that's a really
hard pill to swallow but people who were
taking out student loans they
caught on to the show and they're going
oh my gosh i don't want to take any more
student loans out you may need to
transfer schools you may have to because
i mean you may be a place you can't
afford yeah you may look up and buy i
bought a car i can't afford it i saw the
car and it's inconvenient in the short
term but long run
it's completely worth the effort well i
mean there's so much emotion tied to i
got in and this is my school
but it's true i mean you know
a lot of emotion tied to that and i get
it i get it i mean it's nice to go
somewhere the emotion is legitimate but
it's a bad decision-making tool right
and it can be very costly in the long
run oh it can be out of control yeah in
order just to not deal with the emotion
of moving schools and how painful that
would be
uh you end up 150 000 in debt that would
be under the stupid column yeah you know
because you wouldn't deal with you
and uh it's just hard it really is and
it's like
i was talking to a dad the other day
he's like my my daughter's dream school
and it's going to be 200 000 she's going
to be 200 000 in debt when she comes out
and i'm like that's not your daughter's
dream school that's called a nightmare
it's not a dream it's a nightmare dad
you have to grow you know dad come on
suck it up tell your daughter she's
being a
don't do it don't do it tell her she's
being dumb
and you know no don't participate in
this
ridiculous process
no
no it's not a dream
when you're 200 000 in debt that's not a
dream
that that that sets you up for a decade
you set you're setting your finances
back a decade
because of your dream school oh shoot me
it is not your dream it's a freaking
nightmare you ought to wake up in the
middle of night screaming
like you just had a horrible like you
went to a horror movie in your head
no it's a nightmare it's a nightmare
no it's not a dream
don't confuse the two and dads and moms
be a parent
be a parent look at them and say no
i'm old crusty and i'm not dumb
no you're not doing that you're young
wet behind the ears and dumb no you're
not doing that i love you too much to
let you create a decades worth of pain
for yourself